foreign
what's up Mary
hello John how are you good and you
I'm doing very well thank you
outstanding appreciate you appreciate
you taking my call and seeing what we
can do about this all right let's do it
what's up
okay so I am engaged to a man
um this is both of our second marriages
we're
um early 50s uh prior marriages those 20
plus years
um and all that we've been together over
two years uh engaged for about a year of
that
in the beginning of our relationship
um he was very open with me about why
his prior marriage ended and that was
because he had
he was in a very toxic relationship that
had been in order to cope with that
which using escort services for
probably five to ten years or so and
this was all done very covertly his his
ex knew nothing about it until one day
she discovered a piece of mail about a
declination of of a credit application
that he was trying to get additional
credit
um in his name a little
he had an apartment with this person
with this escort that he was being very
regularly almost in a relationship type
of situation
[Music]
um and so this was discovered his
divorce ensued and
you know they tried to go through
counseling
um you know and you know we can only
believe so much about what people tell
us about their past that he did show me
the divorce papers and confirmed that
this is a legitimate story
um and so I was very grateful to get you
know have him come clean
um
you know and I'm certainly not perfect
either with my prior marriage
um not in in that sense of the meaning
but you know in other things where I
recognized where I had failures as well
um so moving forward
um we've have great chemistry is like
zero drama like it's so refreshing to
have zero drama with somebody
um and so
you know in the last we had some
financial difficulties this early spring
he lost his job
um and was you know able to to get by
um I didn't have to cover him or
anything but it was you know he's a very
proud man in terms of wanting to be a
good provider and so that puts some
stress on him
and I felt like something was off and so
I did confront him and I felt like this
is it's more than just the finances
what's going on
and he admitted that
um you know and he showed me his phone
in his email where these escort service
ads started to roll into his inbox again
in April
um I you know I confronted him about it
he was very open with it he's never
hidden his phone from me but just I
don't routinely look at stuff because
it's just not in my nature I'd rather
just trust and deal with whatever
happens I don't want to be
I don't feel like a grown man needs a
babysitter if you know what I mean
absolutely
um so
I'm just really disappointed
um
I knew from the beginning that it would
be a risk
I don't I don't believe that he has
actually taken action on that but the
fact that it's rolling in his inbox is
still I do it's a very risky Behavior
yeah I do did not fall back into that
pattern of a coping mechanism well like
Mary these these things
I've got multiple email addresses for
different things
not one time has an escort service
well not one time as an escort service
just rolled into my inbox yeah I know
that's not how that works so and so I
didn't believe the story that it was
just you said oh I have this account
open that I didn't realize was still
open that's bull crap I want to log into
that account and he absolutely knew it
was open of course he did so I I don't
buy that he's not
um
for lack of better words that he's not
using again
right I don't either the the challenge
here is
the reason this is escalated risk if you
will is
um
I and hear me parse this out this isn't
a moral parsing or a character logical
parsing or even me trying to get queued
this is me just talking about safety
um there is
somebody who's married who has a
one-night fling after an office party
with an office co-worker there's that
right
there is somebody who has meet somebody
at work or meet somebody at the park
where their kids play and they develop a
long-term emotional affair
there is long-term sexual affairs with
people when they're not when they're
married all that stuff happens
but an escort is a physical biological
risk to me that an escort using escort
services in my opinion is a whole other
layer because you're not just the
illusion when you have a one-night stand
or the illusion that you you know when
you have an affair is you are just
um just this is just between me and that
person now that's a stupid thing to say
because you're going to crush somebody
emotionally you might put them at risk
um and when I say risk I'm talking about
STI risk I'm talking about all kinds of
risks by the way this is different
this is putting the very bed you lay in
in significant risk
and this is one of the few moments when
I would throw my hands up and step way
way way way back
that's that's why I wrote you
because I I know it it's you know it's
it's not even about trusting so much
because I've never known a man not to
Cheat It Started With My Father I don't
know four or five times I don't and I'm
not a great guy
and I'm not I'm not perfect just just
know they're out there and statistically
speaking there's more of them than those
that do
it's you deciding I'm not I've got a bad
my picker's broken I guess well I
we marry our unfinished business right
right
so my guess is
you're gonna you're gonna make sure that
you are able to to fix that
and you can't fix that
because most of the time Affairs have
nothing to do with the partner sometimes
they do but they have to do with
somebody going out and feeling alive
again
or somebody trying to cover up shame
right well it's the same thing because
if I know that he has difficulty
makes him feel like a man again escort
doesn't care it makes him feel like a
man again
that's right it's cheap cheap Dime Store
masculinity that's right that's right
it's bull crap it's fake but all that to
say is
he has chosen by his behavior to put
your actual physical health in
significant Danger
period yeah because there's some things
you can't you can't that's right get an
antibiotic form so if I'm you like and I
let's just pretend you're my sister okay
or you're one of my close friends who's
a girl a woman I would say
um Step number one is I'd go get tested
that'd be step number one and that's for
me and my health
step number two is I'd probably go sit
down with a counselor because you've
been through this before
and this is going to have some
significant weight to it
and the way you couched your previous
marriage that you weren't perfect and
you did some things the just the way you
said that tells me that you were
probably in an abusive relationship and
you have mined the depths of yourself to
figure out what you did to cause some of
that fair
true well I also responded in a toxic
way I didn't yeah you made dumb choices
on the back end that's fine yeah yeah
that's fine
um I mean it's not fine you know what I
mean right it happens but
um
and by the way this guy in his previous
marriage
I don't care how toxic it gets he made a
choice right to endanger everybody so he
wasn't forced into this he didn't his
bad marriage didn't cause this
right and he he continues to deflect and
blame her for nope nope she may have
been the worst person in the world in
the world in the world great he gets to
wake up every day and decide am I going
to be a person of integrity and
character even if that means I'm going
to be a person of character and
integrity as I end my marriage because
it's unsafe
fine yes but I didn't do that too so I'm
also guilty of not doing that that
doesn't mean that doesn't that's
you've chosen the shame route you put
that in your backpack and you're
choosing to carry it around as an I am
statement instead of that's something I
did and that will never happen again
right yeah that's fair stop carrying
that around
you did that it happened and there's a
period and then you get to do something
different this time
and this is why I'm just part of my
question to you is since I just give up
and get a dog because it cannot seem to
no be attracted to somebody that doesn't
do this
I think I think it's time probably for
the first time ever
that you go see a true trauma therapist
and say I need this I need to heal my
body from the inside out
in that journey I have been through some
trauma therapy that it was for the prior
relationship that apparently I still
have work to do I think you got it yeah
there's a difference between trauma
therapy that allows you to
um breathe post significant trauma
but in this situation you're going back
and you have a little girl in there
that's still asking daddy why he kept
running around
and why he didn't show up and that's the
stuff you got to deal with
and my guess is my guess is don't answer
this question but my guess is
uh Mary's Life as a little girl as a
young teenager it was really tough
real real real tough
so that's what we got to go sit down
because your body's going to continue to
antenna and direct you towards these
toxic relationships until you can
completely unhook from this need to go
solve
and instead connect to Anchor into the
truth that is I'm Mary and I'm worth
being loved
and I'm worth not being cheated on Not
all men are cheaters
I'm worth
um
I don't know any number of things
I'm worth all of it
I'm especially worth more than this
I'm going to end this the same way I
always do I'm not going to tell you to
end your relationship that's on you I
don't want you saying this podcaster
said I had to do that
um but I wanted to tell you that as
you've laid it out you're not safe
physically or emotionally
and um it's time to take some action to
First protect yourself second heal
yourself and then begin to ask hard
questions about this relationship and
relationships moving forward
thank you so much for the call Mary
we'll be with you holler anytime I can
help